تتمثل مهمتي حقًا في إظهار مدى
جمال التواضع في صناعة الأزياء ،
فأنا بالتأكيد انتقائي للغاية في
الخيارات التي أقوم بها فيما يتعلق بالعارضات
التي ستنضم إلى قائمة الوكالة
خارج نطاق إلقاء نظرة تعرف أن
عارضاتهم حصلوا على  التناسق وعظام الوجنتين
وكل هذه الأنواع من الأشياء ولكنك
تعلم خارج الكليشيه هو حقًا
ما الذي تمثله كيف تعيش
حياتك ، لذلك بالنسبة لي أبحث عن
المرأة العصرية المتواضعة وعندما أقول إنني
أعني أنها في حمضك النووي مثل  هذه هي الطريقة
التي تعيش بها حياتك عندما أسمع أي شيء
سلبي عن المسلمين أو أي شيء
سلبي عن النساء المسلمات بشكل أكثر
تحديدًا ، فهو يدفعني حقًا إلى
القيام بهذه المهمة حقًا ، وإخراج هذا
المفهوم إلى هناك والسماح للناس برؤية مدى
جمال هذه التسعة وكيف يمكن أن تكون
يمكن أن تكون النساء المحتشمات الجميلات
لأن الصورة تساوي ألف كلمة ، لذا
إذا كان بإمكاني أن أعرضها بدلاً من قول الكثير ،
فإنها تصبح صورة أكبر
بالنسبة لي والتي تشبه التثقيف من خلال
الموضة  يعني أنه إذا كان بإمكاني فعل ذلك ،
تحقق مني وانتهيت من ذلك